Christopher rouffeau has this report it
says the new animated film for kids mama
has a mustache is sponsored by Abby V
which is the pharmaceutical company that
sells the chemical castration drug
Lupron to convicted pedophiles and quote
transgender children a little bit more
on this um animated film which is
sponsored not just by this
pharmaceutical company but by others as
well but first let's watch the uh I
guess this is the trailer for this
piece of propaganda watch
so what's the first question can you be
a girl and have a boy body or be a boy
and have a girl body yes
can this person be a parent yes my dad
[Music]
I feel like I'm not really a boy or a
girl
[Music]
mama has a mustache mommy has a mustache
by the way I was curious about the film
itself this propaganda film and um I
tried went to look up where where can
you find it
um
not that it's a a something that I would
enjoy watching but it is something that
I'm I'm interested to see for the
purposes of debunking it and uh you it's
it's not available like you have to
they kind of keep it under lock and key
they're not making it widely available
to everybody which is uh
not a surprise because that's exactly
what they don't want exactly what they
don't want is someone like me watching
it and going through to picking up
picking it apart
um so you can access it but you got to
go you gotta scientific basically fill
like an application form to access the
film
although we've seen enough from it just
based on that
uh and it it will never fail to just
absolutely disgust and infuriate me when
um
I see any kind of propaganda like this
but especially you know you hear the
child
hear one of the children one of the
abused children being exploited for this
thing
say uh well I I love myself
which is good
right because you should love yourself
and we should teach our kids our
children to love themselves and accept
themselves for who they are
um that's an important message
because the other option is
self-loathing the other option is to
reject to want to reject who you
naturally are
and yes we should be we should be
teaching our kids to love themselves but
that is is exactly
what this kind of propaganda does not
teach
teaches the opposite
under the guise of loving yourself it
actually teaches kids to hate themselves
to hate who they are
to to try to destroy who they actually
are
with drugs and surgery if necessary
for the the sake of obtaining some kind
of image an image that they didn't even
come up with an image that was given to
them by the propagandists by the
groomers
uh Breitbart has more on this story it
says a pro-transgender propaganda film
for children called Mama has a mustache
was sponsored by bear a um a
pharmaceutical company that produces
drugs that are used to feminize men who
identify as transgender
mama has a mustache is all about
normalizing transgenderism particularly
in the minds of one group of people and
that is young children the film's
website Bears the phrase kids talk
gender directly above the trailer which
starts with a child being asked can you
be a girl and have a boy body or be a
boy and a girl body we heard that
um
the synopsis of mama has a mustache
leaves no room for doubt about the
film's intentions to mold the minds of
young children the film is driven
completely by Audio interviews of kids
ages 5 to 10 and explores how children
are able to experience a world outside
of the traditional gender binary
and of course we're supposed to be
getting uh the child's perspective but
we're not actually getting the child's
perspective we're getting the child
these children repeating the propaganda
that's been fed to them so we're getting
adult
disseminated propaganda fed through the
mouths of children
kids didn't come up with anything kids
didn't come up with with the gender
identity kids didn't come up with the
idea that you could be a boy a girl in a
boy's body no no child developed that
idea that was developed by the groomers
and the Predators and kids are being
made to repeat it
but the point here is that you've got it
seems at least two pharmaceutical
companies
that are behind this film that have
helped to sponsor it
um
and we see again where the lefts uh you
know their the this pose they strike of
being critical of Corporations and
skeptical of big money influence and all
of that all of that reveals itself to be
just that oppose it's all that's all it
is
I wish it were true
you know and I think for a long time the
right bought into this too much they
bought into this uh you know this this
notion that the left is like demonizing
corporations and demonizing rich people
and I think simply demonizing
corporations demonizing rich people is
simplistic
but I wish that it was true I wish that
that was I wish that was the mistake the
left made being overly simplistic in
their in their condemnations of money
and rich people and corporations
I wish that was true
but it's not true at all of course
because if you are going to be skeptical
of
billion dollar corporations
um the first place you should be looking
and the first place where you should be
directing that skepticism is to the
pharmaceutical industry
doesn't mean all all drugs that uh the
pharmaceutical industry produces are bad
necessarily
I think a lot of them are they're not
all bad
but this is a multi-billion dollar
industry that um
makes all that money
not just by not just by uh
treating sickness
but by convincing people they are sick
so that they can then treat it
and this comes in many forms and it
includes most nefariously
and insidiously the you know convincing
children that they're sick with this
gender dysphoria so then can be treated
by the drugs they provide and that'll do
it for this portion of the show as we
move over to the members block hope to
see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]